today's episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream an incredible and
incredibly affordable place to watch
thousands of non-fiction movies and
shows more on them in a bit
it was perhaps the most dramatic birth
this channel will ever cover in january
2004 a bright spot of light streaked
across the skies of arabia terra the
burning ball of fire slicing through the
atmosphere at over 16 000 kilometers per
hour far above the empty desert wastes
but this was no ordinary shooting star
and this was no ordinary desert and
inside the fireball was one of the most
advanced pieces of kit ever created a
rover designed to shatter science
records its destination the frozen
windswept plains
of the planet mars if the rover survived
its traumatic birth the plan was to have
it live in this hostile environment for
up to 90 martian days 90 days in which
it would travel perhaps one kilometer
from its landing site conducting science
experiments along the way instead
opportunity would remain active on the
surface of mars for a staggering 14 and
a half years in today's experimental
episode of biographics we're delving
into the life of not a man or a woman
but a machine a robot that traveled to
our celestial neighbor and in doing so
opened humanity's eyes to the wonders of
our solar system
normally when making these biographies
we open unsurprisingly with the
subject's birth but that's just not
gonna work with opportunity by nasa's
definition the rover was born when it
emerged from its protective cocoon
shortly after impacting the surface of
bars on january 25 2004 but starting our
video there would
miss half the story no with this
particular subject we're going to have
to rewrite the rules by opening way
way back back before opportunity was
even just a twinkle in nasa's eye back
in an era when mars exploration more
often than not meant
gigantic really expensive screw-ups the
path that led to opportunity
affectionately known as poppy revving
around the martian surface and charming
us all can be said to have begun on an
utterly miserable day back in 1993 that
day everyone at nasa mission control was
nervously watching as their shiny new
craft approached the red planet for an
expensive mission costing over 800
million mars observer was an orbital
probe that promised to open a whole new
era in martian exploration to map planet
4 in ways that today seem quaint but
1993 folk were groundbreaking or rather
they would have been unfortunately that
fatal day nasa lost contact with mars
observer just 72 hours before orbital
insertion despite whispered prayers
clever seeming solutions and a whole lot
of stress the probe was never heard from
again just like that 800 million dollars
of taxpayer money had been flushed down
a cosmic toilet and that meant there was
going to be hell to pay the aftermath of
the mars observer debacle saw nasa's
biggest institutional shake-up since the
challenger disaster faced with an angry
congress in budget-cutting mode the
space agency hastily implemented a new
policy on the wind buy the motto
faster better cheaper that meant no more
hyper-expensive orbiters instead cheaper
landing craft would spearhead the new
phase of exploration and none would be
twice as celebrated as pathfinder the
first soft landing on mars since the
1976 viking missions pathbinder was
designed to do a whole bunch of
groundbreaking science while also
costing a quarter of the lost mars
observer for our story though the key is
that the lander came with a bold little
experiment attached to it one that would
pave the way for not just opportunity
but scores of other missions to come the
name of that experiment sojourner
weighing just 11.5 kilograms and little
more than half a meter long sojourner
was opportunity's direct ancestor a tiny
adorable little robot that ventured away
from pathfinder on a mission all of its
own being the first martian rover
sojourner's baby steps were attentive at
best over a lifespan of 83 martian days
known as souls it covered a mere 100
meters but in doing so
it changed history in the same way the
wright brothers initial flight time of
12 seconds was both unimpressive
sounding and an utter game changer
sojourner's adventure opens a galaxy of
possibilities unfortunately those
possibilities were soon put on ice by
even more nasa budget cuts which made a
second mars rover an unaffordable luxury
thankfully though events would soon
conspire to change the agency's mind
after 1993 1999 is the other great year
of nasa martian screw-ups in the space
of three months two probes the mars
climate orbiter and the mars polar
lander were lost or destroyed in one
case because of a humiliating mix-up
between metric and imperial units the
death of the two probes put a temporary
break on martian exploration as nasa
slammed the 2001 launch window shut to
conduct a review there would be no more
mars missions until 2003. the steep
squares ray arvidsson and larry
soderblom this pause would turn out to
be exactly what they needed scientists
and former rivals the three had spent
the last decade pitching separate mars
projects to nasa only to see them lose
out to faster and cheaper options now is
faster cheaper better seem to be dying
the trio began to put their rivalry
aside they began working instead on a
team pitch one might not be cheap but
would certainly be better a pitch that
would ultimately see them take the
unofficial roll of opportunities parents
it was the moment of the rover's
conception the spark that would soon
light up the history of mars but not
before opi underwent one of the most
stressful and traumatic deliveries
in history
[Music]
you've got to hand it to nasa
administrator daniel s golden although
he initially balked at sending another
costly rover to mars when he finally got
the idea he really got it looking over
the plan to onrover he asked and said
why not send two that way they'd have
built in redundancy in case one went the
way of the mars observer it would also
mean that they could land them on
separate parts of the planet and study
entirely different kinds of rock from a
mission viewpoint it was an awesome
suggestion squares and arvidsson's whole
pitch was that rovers would essentially
be robot geologists using their expert
eye to tell us what orbiters never could
from a viewpoint of every single
engineer at jpl though
it was a sheer heart attack the nasa
green light came in mid-2000 with an
immovable mid-2003 launch date squared
and co had estimated that they'd need 48
months to build the rovers nasa just
gave them 34. and so began the most
stressful three years of the engineering
team's lives for opportunity under
sister over spirit this was akin to
their period of gestation the robot
equivalent of the nine months we humans
spend chilling out inside the womb
absorbing nutrients and making our
mothers rue being heavily pregnant at
the height of summer and just like human
pregnancy it was hell on the rest of the
body at the jet propulsion laboratory
jpl work on opportunities hardware and
software alike took place 24 hours a day
seven days a week it was split between
three eight-hour shifts it was grueling
not only were the twin rovers giant golf
cart sized things that weighed 185
kilograms each they also needed to be
equipped with all sorts of cameras and
funky science experiments that sojourner
never had to worry about the software
too was a nightmare because of the time
lag between sending a signal from earth
and receiving it on mars rovers on
planet four can't be steered in real
time that means they need to be capable
of doing some stuff independently which
also means they're far more complex to
program in fact opportunity software was
so complex that she was receiving
patches right up until the moment of her
birth updates that were beamed across
the gulf of space even as she was
already on her way to that remote and
forbidding planet yet even amid the
stress around her gestation there was
still time for some precious moments
perhaps the most precious of all was the
inclusion of a tiny bit of scrap metal
within her body requested by part of the
engineering team based in new york that
tiny piece of metal had been salvaged
from the wreck of the twin towers a
twisted fragment of the buildings that
were destroyed on 9 11. including parts
of it within opportunity and spirit was
intended as a tribute to the families to
show that american spirit had not been
crushed not that the rovers actually
went by their names at this point like
many unborn children they'd not yet been
named officially nasa referred to them
as m-e-r-a and m-e-r-b for mars
exploration rovers unlike most unborn
children though it wouldn't be their
parents that named their overs but
rather a nine-year-old orphan from
siberia in 2003 nasa launched a
competition to name its new rovers this
being an innocent free social media time
the winner or wasn't marzie mcmahon's
face but a short essay by the young
adoptee sophie carlos who recalled how
the distant stars outside her russian
orphanage's window made her feel less
lonely now she wrote in america i can
make all my dreams come true thank you
for the spirit and the opportunity the
names became official in june that same
year just in time for takeoff on july
the 7th 2003 a rocket blasted off from
cape canaveral into the humid night sky
on a 455 million kilometer journey on
board was opportunity traveling nearly a
month behind her twin less than seven
months later the two would be on mars
but only if they survived the journey
because as we're about to see the
official birth of these two rovers
wasn't a time of great beauty or joy
but of nail biting stress
so here you are in the middle of an
educational video on youtube i'm gonna
make what i think is a fairly safe bet
that you rather like learning things and
if i'm right i think you're going to
love the sponsor of today's episode
curiosity stream look if you're a
regular viewer of this channel you know
that we've covered a lot of military
figures lots of battles and wars so i'd
recommend you check out apocalypse world
war one on curiosity stream it's made
from over 300 hours of archival footage
from world war one and it traces the
journeys of civilians and soldiers who
fought for survival in one of the
darkest times in history it's a deep
dive from the wars outbreak in 1914 to
the u.s intervention and the signing of
the treaty of versailles if you like the
stuff we publish here you're going to
love that show on curiosity plus you can
watch curiosity stream pretty much
anywhere grab a few minutes on your
phone or put it up on the big screen tv
whatever you like it's also available
worldwide so you can access their full
library of content anywhere and speaking
of content you're never going to run out
because in addition to the thousands of
programs already on their service
there's new shows being added every week
so go to
curiositystream.com biographics for
unlimited access the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series for
you guys use the promo code biographics
and you'll save 25 which comes out to
only 14.99 a year it's just 1.25 a month
which is super affordable and now back
to today's episode
for a brief moment in early 2004 it
looked like nasa might have another mars
observer on their hands on january the
4th spirit had landed in the gusev
crater three weeks ahead of her sister
there the first 18 souls had crept by
without any problems and then sol 19
began
and nasa lost all contact in the
agonizing days that followed it become
clear that a a software bug was to blame
and b the still unborn opportunity
likely suffered the same problem
suddenly it began to seem like 1993 or
99 all over again like yet another
mission was destined to bite the dust
leaving the combined
820 million dollars spent on the rovers
to evaporate into the orange martian
skies but you already know that's not
what happened with perhaps the loudest
exclamation of relief ever uttered by
humans the engineers were able to locate
the issue and fix it a patch was sent to
opportunity while she was still in space
and a scientific miscarriage was averted
and so we get to where our introduction
began with a streak of light shining
like a crazy diamond over the martian
desert a farbel that on january the 25th
2004 landed on meridiani planet it
wasn't exactly a gentle landing boat
unlike the controlled descents later
rovers like curiosity would utilize
opportunity came crashing to earth
inside a giant cocoon of airbags 26
separate times it smacked into the
planet's surface before bouncing back up
and across the desert wastes finally it
came to arrest an eagle crater shortly
after a whirring could be heard and at
long long last opportunity peered out
onto the world that she had been born
into it was a world unlike anything
anyone on earth
expected to see at this point you have
to remember that there had been very few
probes on mars the american landers that
had taken pictures vikings one and two
and pathfinder had all returned images
that looked similar of a barren
landscape strewn by rocks so an
opportunity peered out on a completely
different terrain all sand and craters
and distant cliffs it had been like
seeing a brand new planet a mars that
would be her home for the rest of her
extremely short life
and yes
it was short while we've been utilizing
our opportunity as a living creature
metaphor to talk about human things like
gestation and birth no one at nasa
remotely expected their baby to last as
long as any mammal instead opportunity
was designed to be something more like a
mayfly a rover that would hatch out of
its cocoon of airbags and then live a
mere 90 souls before expiring the reason
for this
all that martian dust unlike today's
nuclear-powered rovers opportunity and
her sister were solar-powered the
expectation was that this would be fine
for around 90 souls at which point so
much dust would collect on the panels
that
they'd stopped working that meant oppie
had to start her short life at a sprint
and gather as much data as fast as
possible that's exactly what she did
barely in newborn the rover began
examining a landing site and almost
immediately turned science on its head
by analyzing tiny spheres of hematite
nasa dubbed blueberries opportunity
discovered they'd been formed several
billion years ago was a liquid water
flowed across them it was the first
direct evidence of liquid water once
flowing across the surface of mars a
major stepping stone for assessing if
the planet was ever inhabitable sadly
the evidence at this stage was less that
mars had been a nurturing mother and
more like a killer queen the rock sophie
examined could have only been formed by
extremely acidic water still it was a
major achievement for the young rover it
was about to be followed by a far
happier one on april 4th 2004 something
strange happened that day spirit crossed
the 90s soul mark thereby outliving its
expected life span less than a month
later opportunity did otherwise now that
in itself wasn't super unusual nasa
intentionally lowballs mission lifespan
so everyone's happy when its probes
exceed them what was unusual though was
that spirit and opportunity then just
kept on living and living
and living it turned out the martian
winds were stronger than anyone had
realized so strong they periodically
blasted all the accumulated dust off the
rover solar panels in other words
opportunity might be able to keep going
for years even so it would surprise
everyone just how long the plucky little
rover managed to live for
in many ways the mid to late 2000s can
be thought of as opportunities salad
days a time of life characterized by
being young and carefree as her
controllers on earth were swept along on
the currents of ordinary life through
financial meltdowns and elections past
debt crises and austerity opportunity
simply kept trundling along on mars
following her simple
remarkable mission she was just finding
out as much about the red planet as
possible in this she was helped
immensely by her sibling ozopi was busy
examining endurance crater and
identifying the first meteor i'd ever
found on mars on the other side of the
planet spirit was making discoveries of
her own while opportunity's landing site
had been the jackpot in terms of science
spirit had touched down in a place that
everyone agreed looked remarkably boring
in fact it looked so boring that it was
only due to a massive fluke that the
rover made her greatest discovery on a
drive through some loose dirt spirit
developed a drag on one of her wheels
this wound up digging a small trench as
she moved which revealed the soil
beneath was brighter in fact it was
almost pure silica and to be created in
such quantities would almost certainly
have involved water interacting with
rock at a high temperature such as
around springs or hydrothermal vents and
that in turn provided yet more evidence
of an ancient mars that once appeared
not red and dusty but blue with seas
it's easy to forget now but until
opportunity and spirit arrived we had no
confirmation if our neighbor ever had
liquid surface water their joint
discoveries transformed our
understanding of the early solar system
and they opened the door for a question
that still haunts science exploration to
this very day given evidence of ancient
water might mars have once played host
to alien life
this is serious philosophical stuff had
the rovers now died after these two
independent confirmations of liquid
water in the distance past they would
have been remembered as major successes
and that's fortunate because dying is
almost what they did as much as we've
romanticized opie's mission there mars
is a hostile and unforgiving environment
even for robots in 2007 a massive dust
storm picked up enveloping the planet in
a howling nightmare of near darkness
with the already faint sun reduced to a
missmudge in an evil sky opportunity was
barely able to get any juice from her
solar panels from an average of 700 a
power dropped to only 128 watt hours a
near terminal decline that threatened to
plunge her into eternal night for six
long weeks mission control waited like
an anxious parent watching over a badly
ill child waiting to see if she'd pull
back from the brink or simply fade away
before their eyes finally the storm
abated the surface of mars grew calm
once more and there on the windswept
plane she still stood opportunity her
solar panels clean enough to function
a journey far from over sadly though it
would be a journey that she'd mostly
make alone while spirit had likewise
survived the mid-2007 dust storm the
rover's twin wouldn't be around much
longer on may 1 2009 her wheels got
stuck in soft soil on the edge of a
plateau leaving her unable to move for
nearly a year nasa tried everything
eventually it was decided to use her
like one of the agency's former landers
and a mobile platform conducting science
in one place all there to do was tilt
her solar panel slightly so she'd get
enough sunlight over the martian winter
but even this alas
would prove to be too much on march the
22nd 2010 nasa lost contact with spirit
despite over a year of trying the rover
never again responded to any of their
commands finally on may 25 2011 they
announced the inevitable opportunity's
sister was gone now little more than a
lifeless piece of metal turning gold
over half a world away opi was now
officially alone on mars
[Music]
after her twins untimely death
opportunity dealt with the loss in the
same way that many humans do she kept
herself busy setting off on a new
mission to explore the 23 kilometer wide
endeavor crater and its ancient rocks
because the journey involved a long
detour and a swath of soft sand it would
wind up taking three years three years
in which opi would break the first of
many records on may 20 2010 two months
after spirit stopped responding obvi
completed the 116th day of her mission's
seventh year and that's an important
number because it's the length of time
the viking one had survived on the
martian surface which meant that
opportunity was now the longest running
mars surface mission in history from a
science standpoint though the most
impressive moment came after the rover
finally reached endeavour in august 2011
those ancient rocks the crater held
turns out they were perhaps the oldest
mars rocks ever studied and they too
told what was by now becoming a familiar
story formed by non-acidic running water
some four billion years ago the rocks
confirmed that mars was once home to
rushing rivers deltas and churning seas
surface water that lasted perhaps 500
million years it was another amazing
find more confirmation that mars had
once been conducted to life yet it was
also perhaps the last gasp of
opportunity as the cutting-edge science
tool that she'd been designed to be
already the next generation is well on
its way on august 5th 2012 the first of
that new generation arrived when
curiosity rover parachuted into gale
crater some 8 400 kilometers from opi
within a decade it would be joined by
even more advanced pieces of kit from
nasa's perseverance rover and ingenuity
helicopter to china's zurong rover with
these new arrivals came a subtle shift
in the center of gravity while
opportunity would keep making
discoveries she'd no longer be at the
forefront instead her fame would come to
rest more on her incredible longevity
not to mention all the records broken in
may 2013 that included breaking the nasa
record for distance covered on a
celestial object overtaking the
35.744 kilometers clocked in 1972 by the
apollo 17 lunar roving vehicle a year
later in july 2014 she broke the overall
distance record snatching the crown away
from the soviet union's luna hot 2 which
clocked 39 kilometers on the moon in
1973. by march 2015 she became the first
human design machine to finish a
marathon on another world crossing the
42.195 kilometer boundary yet even as
she pushed the bounds of human
engineering to breaking point there was
no getting around one sadly obvious fact
the solid days such as they were were
now long over and oppy was getting old
like in a human the sides of aging
manifest themselves physically a joint
that became stiff and wouldn't work
properly a wheel that could no longer
steer eventually even her memory started
to go commands would be forgotten the
robot equivalent of walking into a room
one day and wondering to yourself why
am i here still at least her longevity
was at last bringing opie the
recognition she'd always deserved back
on earth the rover had become a
celebrity the cameras should come
equipped with easily repurposed for the
craze of posting selfies to social media
to be fair she'd always been famous
though by 2017 some of her operators
could remember excitedly following news
for adventures back in 2004
when they were still in high school but
this was a whole new level oppy's age
had turned her into a fundamental fact
of life for millions come the late 2010s
she was like an elderly relative or a
beloved pet something you simply can't
imagine not being around but of course
even the longest lived companion
eventually dies the old dog is taken to
the vet one last time the grandparent
shuffles off to the great bingo hall in
the sky and now opi's time had finally
come
[Music]
in may of 2017 the rover began its final
mission investigating a guardian on the
edge of the giant endeavour crater known
as perseverance valley nasa scientists
were hoping to figure out if the gully
had been carved by wind or running water
but they'd never get a definitive answer
in summer 2018 oppy was beginning her
descent into the crater when another
mars-wide dust storm blew up out of
nowhere initially the team on earth
weren't concerned they'd ridden out the
2007 planetary storm without problems
and well how could this one be worse
than that
well it turned out the answer was rather
easily the 2018 dust storm was simply
one of the greatest planet-wide storms
to ever hit mars at the height of the
2007 storm the sun had at least been a
faint smudge in the sky at the height of
this one it simply vanished the whole
planet was shrouded in darkness for
weeks on end and while curiosity's
nuclear battery meant that it would
survive no problem the same couldn't be
said for the solar powered opi initially
loss of contact with the rover was
regarded as temporary even though her
solar panels were undoubtedly covered
with the dust it was hoped that the
strong marshall wins the blow from
november to january every year would
clean her as they had so many times
before there were a few who thought this
might really be the end in early 2019
though it became clear that the strong
winds would fail to clean her panels
this time for weeks on end nasa sent off
all sorts of commands hoping to jolt her
out of her slumber hoping to give her
one last burst of life but it was not to
be on january 25 2019 as american news
sites were otherwise transfixed with a
looming federal government shutdown nasa
sent its final signal to opportunity
she never responded a couple of weeks
later on the evening of february the
12th the ground crew gathered in the
control room for an impromptu wake
someone played i'll be seeing you by
billy holiday a few shed tears the very
next day nasa announced toppy's death to
the world
it was the end of an era as many
obituaries noted the rover had been
launched at an entirely different time a
time in which youtube and smartphones
hadn't yet existed a world in which
george w bush was president barack obama
was million illinois hopeful running for
the senate and donald trump had just
launched a brand new show called the
apprentice a world in which our
knowledge of mars had been a mere
fraction of what it is now overall
opportunity survived on the martian
surface for 5 111 souls or 14 and a half
years and it covered 45.16 kilometers
both of those remain records unbroken on
the surface of any celestial body and
are likely to remain in place for a long
time but of course opportunity was
always about more than simply breaking
records before she and her sister
touched down mars was a remote neighbor
shrouded in mystery a place we'd briefly
touched with three landers and had seen
from orbit but which we had yet to fully
understand today thanks to opie's
pioneering work mars is almost familiar
a place whose vast empty landscapes we
can summon with the swipe of a finger a
place we plan to send yet more rovers to
in the coming decade a place that soon
humans may set foot on and when they
finally do opportunity will be waiting
for them with a landing site meridiani
plan of a possible target for future
crude mission it may not be many decades
before the first astronauts come face to
face with a plucky little rover and when
they do we can only hope that they take
a minute to honor the robot that came
before them the rover that finally
brought humanity face to face
with mars
[Music]